the following conversation is with
Matthew ball the author of the brand new
book The metaverse he's widely
considered a futurist and he continues
to have very fascinating ideas about
where the world is going these
conversations are brought to you by
ftxus click on the link in the
description to learn more about what
they're building over there all right
let's get into this episode I hope you
guys learned just as much as I did
Matthew I think we've got you how are
you great how are you I'm doing uh
fantastic a place that I'd like to start
is uh you've been in and around a bunch
of amazing media businesses uh over time
you were at otter uh you're at Amazon
Studios uh and you had a pretty big hand
in the directions that they chose to
pursue and some of the strategy that
they employed and it feels like although
maybe not directly there is this like
implicit connection between a lot of the
work you did before uh you you kind of
staked a flag in the ground on the
metaverse
um and can you talk a little bit as like
what those past experiences how did they
shape your views as to where you think
the world is going today
sure that's a really great place to
start I started my career in deep Tech
that was Aerospace and defense Oil and
Gas Energy in the mid-2000s so I'm
Canadian so we went through the energy
Spike the oil Rush the Rise of nickel
and other Precious Minerals in Canada
that gave me a really good foundation
for deep infrastructure and Technology
problems those come back when we talk
about the metaverse because we're
talking about really sophisticated 3D
simulations far more so than the games
that we're used to playing but where
that same technology is now playing hand
in those problems but in the interim I
shifted very quickly to the mobile app
economy at the end of the 2000s early
2010s helping Publishers TV broadcasters
video game makers music labels adapt
their businesses to direct to consumer
or at least consumer-facing digital
products after that when I was at the
churning group's Auto media division we
were cultivating unique digital first
communities brands e-commerce businesses
whether that was Crunchyroll or bar
stool Sports
subsequent to that I went to Amazon as
you would teed up and that was building
out one of the world's largest ever
premium Media Company
those all converge into this idea of the
metaverse very deep technological
requirements but all focused on a global
community of media of new business
models and experiences so I think the
very first piece of your work that I
came across was you were talking I think
through the lens of Amazon Studios about
the movie business and how the
intellectual property was going to be so
important and really your thought
process was like you may have a
relationship with this IP over the past
you know decades where you went you
watched a movie you like the movie and
then you kind of laughed maybe told some
friends about it but that was almost the
the uh extent of your relationship with
that IP it's pretty simple to see okay
well maybe we should get into you know
stuffed animals or toys or that type of
stuff but you then extended it out and
said well actually there's going to be
even further extensions where you're
going to see video games that are built
on the movies and talk a little bit as
to how you see uh the intellectual
property that may have just been a movie
in the past really now kind of seeping
into these various media formats because
I think that that in some way is the
easiest way for people to understand
this idea of a metaverse it's kind of
like a low Fidelity version and then we
can talk about how it'll get improved
over time
so this is really fun because we can
start Millennia ago and I don't mean to
sound academic or obtuse but you know
there was an idea that the mythologies
that we told Greco-Roman mythology was
immersive the idea was that Zeus May
literally be a swan that you pass on
your street they lived in and around us
most of our early advances in technology
around entertainment were designed to
reinforce that medieval Gardens
pre-medieval Gardens were arranged with
gargoyles and other epic statues to
bring you closer to that experience it
wasn't just go look at shrubs beautiful
arrangements and flowers it was to get
closer to that Supernatural Fantastical
idea that extends into the 20th century
of course we would go see Star Wars in
1977 but for many of us we would then go
home and imagine more of it we would go
into the bathtub as an infant and play
with a Luke Skywalker figurine
what has changed over the past 20 years
is what technology can provide in
particular
that is live that is semi curated by the
audience that is nearly persistent and
it has a visual Fidelity that we've
never before achieved if that makes
sense that we can access our stories
more often with more people no matter
where we are with greater capability it
makes sense that we're falling deeper
and deeper in love with the stories we
love most if you don't want to
see Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles you'd
rather spend more time with Captain
America you can in 2022 you couldn't in
1982. what's interesting about this is I
think of young kids and in some way uh
they are immersed in these worlds and
they adults May kind of uh talk down to
them ignore them kind of thumb their
nose and say oh that's just what young
kids do but if you think of those young
children they have the actual uh you
know toys they have the movies that they
watched it seems like on repeat uh TV
shows like we have seen this in maybe
more of like the animation space uh for
children is this really what we're
talking about just extending it to kind
of more of an adult audience but also
pushing out onto new platforms or New
Media types as well where it's not just
okay you have the toy you have the movie
maybe we get a theme park and like let's
call it a day there's all these new
surfaces and kind of platforms that we
can go to
so there's two angles to that one is to
talk about the ways in which we've
destigmatized virtual enjoyment and
sandbox play if you go back five years
ago and it was not considered cool it
was often seen as anti-social to come
home and spend hours and hours building
in Minecraft it was very much the young
Millennial version of a 40 year old man
who comes home after work and he goes
into his basement to play with his train
set you shouldn't do that if you have
something better to do the pandemic has
destigmatized that quite extensively we
know that the capabilities the shared
experiences the creative expression is
extraordinary and so that's a big part
of that we actually know that everyone
likes to imagine fictional worlds but we
were basically told that after year 12
unless you're really talented and
professionally focused on it you
shouldn't do it but the second part is
industry the Technologies which Run game
engines game physics game rendering
today are now being used to live operate
the buildings you walk into when you go
into the Hong Kong International Airport
there's a persistent digital twin of you
of this space of every airplane and gate
and worker and that simulation
determines where you go not just well 82
is closed so let's send you to 84. that
is the much bigger opportunity for the
metaverse
what are some of the things you're most
excited about whether it's new platforms
where this is pushing out or specific
pieces of technology that you think
people may not really understand kind of
how quickly this is going to accelerate
so the example that I just used about
the Hong Kong International Airport is
such a fun one because there's this
Eerie gap between what is the world's
most valuable asset class and that is
real estate and what is the world's
largest and most successful development
platform which is the world itself and
how online
real estate and infrastructure is most
buildings you go into they're online to
the extent in which there's Wi-Fi
available your passcode is authenticated
over IP perhaps the security cameras are
being transmitted over IP rather than
recorded to tape
we do almost nothing and that's because
these environments are not legible to
software and that means that when the
local city is issuing permits when you
are building your storefront dependent
in part upon the stores beside you and
what they do and don't do what the city
optimizes for that's all in isolation
it's asynchronous there's years in
between decision making there's no
sharing of information and it's mostly
offline and dumb and so the idea of
going to a 3D collaborative simulation
for the world's largest asset class
largest development platform the longest
running evidence of network effects that
gets me excited when I think of the
metaverse there's maybe two different
definitions or kind of two different
approaches you have what I'll call like
the Mark Zuckerberg uh we're gonna build
virtual reality uh it's gonna be a place
that you go
um and you're going to be able to
experience a lot of the things you're
talking about here uh another version is
uh Sean Perry uh had this great tweet
where he said the metaverse isn't
necessarily a place it's this point in
time where you care more about your
online identity than your real world
identity are both of these right is
there kind of a way to think about like
what is the metaverse and how much of a
place versus a point in time like how do
you kind of balance those two different
ideas
the terminology isn't particularly
important we'll probably find that in
2035 we don't use the term metaverse we
might just say the internet but 3D we
might just say the internet but more we
might use an altogether dissimilar term
in China they've taken to the term hyper
digital reality
but what really matters is this
reflection of the way in which digital
existence virtual existence is different
today it is primarily a window into your
life I take a picture of what I'm doing
in the real world and post it online and
you have a lens into it I work through
Zoom but I don't perform my work on or
in Zoom my labor is real it's paid
electronically the metaverse can be
thought of at minimum the idea that
where I'm sitting and where I exist
is co-experienced in physical and real
space but it can also be considered a
point in time in which a substantial
portion of my identity my wealth my
friendships happiness
are in digital space often personified
and embodied
when you think about that transition
from where we are today to let's call it
the metaverse right and uh kind of
encompasses a bunch of stuff we're
talking about are we going to put kind
of the Oculus on our face you know the
the crude description of like put a box
on our eyeballs right and that's going
to be our entry point
um is it going to be more like a Google
Glass is it VR is it AR is it kind of
everything like how do you just think
about okay today the closest we probably
are to like entering the metaverse or
entering that kind of hyper digital
world is like through our computer
screens or our phones what does that
relationship look like into how we enter
into this digital world in the future
foreign
so most people believe that advances in
augmented reality and virtual reality
headsets are
important or required to substantially
Elevate human existence into these
spaces it's a more intuitive environment
it's better suited to certain use cases
XR surgery a lot more intuitive than
taking a look at a 3D or a 2d screen
representing 3D information
but you shouldn't think of it as a
technical requirement any more than a
smartphone is a technical requirement
for the mobile internet
the internet exists endpoint agnostic
there's 25 billion devices connected to
it not all are smartphones not all even
have a visual interface I can say hey
Google and all of a sudden my cell
phone's going to be on the mobile
internet without ever looking at a
screen
but for the foreseeable future the
technology required to substantially
replace our smartphone or any other
device when used to access 3D worlds
just isn't there Mark Zuckerberg said in
2015 he expected by the end of that
decade we would replace smartphones with
wearables he's since then obviously
missed that timeline but pushed out the
initial release date for his first AR
devices three times they're now not even
going to see a consumer's hand until the
back half of this decade that technology
problem has proven extraordinarily
difficult what has also surprised though
is not just how far out that Tech is but
perhaps how unnecessary it is there are
hundreds of millions of people globally
most of whom are in emerging markets and
billions of people monthly for engaging
in so-called real-time render 3D virtual
worlds regularly forming friendships
collaborating building attending
concerts they're not a requirement VR
and AR they may be important but at
least today we're doing fine with that
so it's very obvious to see how whether
it's virtual reality or augmented
reality uh could play a role for doctors
in training and other types of maybe
Professional Services or kind of
corporate use cases uh there's also a
ton of excitement around the consumer
use case and the ability to go to the
movie to hang out with your friends and
kind of do things that may not have a
direct economic uh kind of optimization
but obviously people get excited about
one of the questions we see in kind of
the Bitcoin and crypto world is is this
a business type entry point and those
are who uh ends up adopting this first
or is it more of the individual retail
and consumer how do you think about
those two different groups and and is
that the right framework to Think
Through for who ends up adopting vrar
and kind of this metaverse world first
so I'd say that one of the interesting
things about the metaverse is a
potential fourth era of computing and
networking is that it seems strange when
you take a look at the economic forecast
that it's coming from a small portion of
the Leisure economy McKinsey KPMG PWC
Citibank Goldman Sachs Morgan Stanley
assume that by the end of the decade the
metaverse will be worth 5 trillion at
the low end 13 trillion in annual
revenue that's out of a likely GDP of
around 120 530 billion globally most of
that utility is coming from industrial
and Enterprise use case we struggle to
imagine that and often find it weird
because today it mostly feels and looks
like gaming and that's where we start to
talk about the crypto community and
where much of this seems essential or at
least we don't have good plausible
Alternatives and that has two different
functions number one is the technology
required to build to operate maintain
the metaverse at least at a Bare Bones
level let's put aside decentralization
user rights whether or not we want to
live in the metaverse or we just have
one
but the extraordinary technical needs
basically require us to make better use
out of everyone's resources your spare
GPU your CPU your extra Broadband
capacity
we could build more stuff that will take
some time we could build better stuff
that's expensive and potentially
unnecessary and so many talk about
ethereum as World computers or the
internet's computers or a global
computer many refer to the old Sun
Microsystems adage that the computer is
the network and the network is the
computer because they believe that these
sort of decentralized systems are a
requirement to pull it off the second
element is to actually have a metaverse
that isn't just technically realized but
one that we want and if we're to contend
with multi-trillion dollar corporations
we need to find a means to consolidate
our activities our contributions not
just our spare gpus but our time our
Attention our energy our resources at
large and that's where many get excited
about the structures of dows and smart
contracts that actually there are many
different groups that are more valuable
than Apple than Microsoft than meta
they're just decentralized but they can
through new technology be coordinated
when you think about these environments
uh money is uh highly important to the
physical world even if it's an
electronic format uh it is the way that
we conduct Commerce it is the way that
we measure uh economic value and it's
ultimately the way that we store
economic value as well
um how do you think about money and its
role in these kind of hyper digital uh
environments and is it more so we're
going to recreate the nation-state kind
of Fiat currencies is it something where
you know Bitcoin provides a digital
currency that can be used or is it
something like I would maybe assign to
more of the gaming communities where
each game actually has its own native
currency to some degree and people will
just have a wallet that has you know 20
or 30 different currencies that they use
in different environments they move uh
in between
so I think that there are some fun ideas
here number one is as flawed as we think
that today's Financial Services industry
is today it's even worse in a virtual
environment and why because there's this
fight to be the payment rail or
gatekeeper the taxing authority of all
things virtual that's a great gig if you
can get it why because if you believe as
McKinsey and others do that there's a
multi-trillion dollar future would be
great if you could forcibly tax all of
it especially at 15 to 30 percent but
even at one and a half to two percent on
the Apple iPhone the only company that
is actually allowed to make a mobile
payment with tap and go is Apple pay
visas not allowed to do it PayPal Square
not trusted
when you take a look at Jensen Huang the
founder and CEO of Nvidia the seventh
largest company in the world he believes
that the metaverse economy will
eventually exceed that of the analog
world so 50 60 70 trillion and so as
broken and flawed expensive subject to
regulatory capture the physical and
digital worlds are the virtual one is
essentially subservient to two and they
use that in numerous ways that seem
increasingly flawed
to maintain that control
and so these questions of is there going
to be a digital currency that spans
multiple different Virtual Worlds I'm
absolutely convicted of that we're
seeing evidence Now is it going to be
blockchain based probably often in many
instances unlikely but what we're seeing
here in the virtual world is really the
same sort of fight that we're seeing
between Bitcoin and Fiat which is this
fundamental understanding that the most
potent technology deployed today
is money not even necessarily abstract
idea of capital money but also the
payment rails that facilitate that
transaction
and there was this funny line the other
day when the EU said that they were
going to unbundle Apple's hegemony over
the app store I saw this lawyer say that
apple is going to fight this case until
the heat death of the universe
and on the one hand
that's terrifying on the other hand you
can see the financial sense and that's a
reflection of every Power that bees
desire to maintain the dominant controls
to Capital Mobility reinvestment
taxation at Large
when you think about uh kind of this
digital environment my mind as many
people jumps to Ready Player one it's
probably if you watch the movie the most
uh visually uh obvious okay this could
be one version uh the downside in that
movie is that once people put on the
headset and they're participating in the
digital world it's amazing when they
take it off they may not live in the
most desirable Place their life may not
be as amazing in the physical world as
it is in the digital world what are some
of the downsides or risks that you are
at least paying attention to and think
that people should be aware of as we
move more and more of our lives our
identities our reputations and and that
uh kind of assets into the digital world
so it's a great question I think that
there are two different aspects number
one
we're 15 17 years into the last era of
computing and networking the mobile and
Cloud era and we've identified many
problems with it platform Power Platform
regulation user rights user security
data security data rights data literacy
toxicity abuse harassment Miss and
disinformation
and most of the Titans today don't have
good answers for that question I think
more broadly the web 3 movement is as
motivated by a belief that it's a
technologically better system but also a
very sincere sense that the trade-off of
the past 15 years was not just
the common defense was that it was a
bilateral trade I got service a for free
and service a was great
and therefore they didn't rob me and yet
the fact that I got a good product let's
say and I'm not trying to make a
specific example Google Earth for free
doesn't mean that I was provided the
value that was fair for what Google
received from me
and so I think as we take a look at the
current state of quote-unquote web 2 we
look at the growing severity of its many
problems the exacerbated gap between
what I receive and what I provide it's
reasonable to worry that we're set for a
future that is worse scarier more
extractive than it is restorative to
societal Collective benefit
the second is who's going to build it as
scary as big Tech seems today they don't
literally operate the virtual atoms of
our parallel existence to get to John's
point if we're talking about living
inside digital space rather than just a
window into digital space then who owns
that space is going to be more powerful
than that who facilitates the window
today
Tim Sweeney the founder and CEO of Epic
Games had a warning in 2016 at the time
no one was paying attention to the
metaverse and he said that should one
company gain control of the metaverse
they will be more powerful than any
Corporation or state on Earth they will
be like a god
that sounds hyperbolic but of course if
you take a look at the forecast Jensen's
50 to 70 billion dollar or trillion
dollar forecast
the company that runs that system
would be more powerful at least versus
Most states
in that world uh identity comes up quite
a bit and uh I think the critics uh
would argue uh hey once you put your
real identity into these systems uh you
are tracked they have your data uh and
it's all of the bad things that that we
know people will uh kind of Levy at
large web 2 companies and and extract
out into web 3 potentially on the other
side there's a belief that no maybe I
actually may have multiple identities
and I always think you know the way you
act on Twitter may be different than
Instagram than on a Foursquare versus a
LinkedIn versus Facebook and so how do
you think about identity and will we
have an explosion of uh pseudonyms and
and even Anonymous users will it be more
so people will manage two or three
identities that are then tied back to
themselves like how does that play out
and full well knowing I'm asking you to
essentially try to guess at a moving
Target but like what do you think makes
the most sense as we sit today
I think what makes the most sense is
what exists today it serves a lot of
important functions both technologically
but also societally think about you as
you exist today how many forms of
identity do you have you might have a
building login you have a passport you
have a social you have a driver's
license
all of these serve different functions
they get you admittance into some areas
sometimes but they don't bring
everything of you when you want to go
into an office Park they require the
identity if you want to go into an H R
Block you require a different form of
identity and if you want to go into a
shopping mall they require none at all
the digital ecosystem is the same we
have a you know handful of common
identities that we use most people in
the United States have an iCloud ID they
have a Gmail account they have a
Facebook account they not only reflect
different forms of yourself but to
different applications sharing different
information with counterparties and
often based on what you choose to share
when why and how again that's a mixture
of functional and technological
rationales but that seems like the best
way to solve going forward I certainly
share the opinion that a single identity
poses a severe risk no matter how it
stored but I'm also not convinced that a
single identity solves a real problem
when you think about kind of the
experience regardless of the identity
that you use inside of these
environments we usually think of visual
as the the sense that is most
manipulated or are kind of leveraged I
did a demo maybe five or six years ago
where I put on a kind of a oculus-like
device I put on headphones and
immediately was standing on top of the
twin towers and as I was doing this the
people putting on the demo then said
move your foot you know six inches to to
the center I hit a rope and out in front
of me I could see a rope my foot could
feel the rope and then they turned on a
small fan and now I could feel as if I
was up on top of this building and I
could hear as if I was up on top of this
building
and I was scared I did not want to walk
on that rope right and uh it gave me
this aha moment around this is not just
a physical thing there are these other
senses and in Ready Player one we see he
get puts on kind of a haptic suit and
and seems to kind of augment the
experience of not just Visual and audio
but also uh with the full body suit is
that where this eventually ends up and
technology has to be developed to give
us all of that sensory control in the
true metaverse or do you think there's
uh maybe a dream of that but it's
unlikely to happen
so we're seeing it right now it's
manifesting a lot faster than I think
many people expect and it partly comes
down to that classic adage which happens
to come from William Gibson's
Neuromancer which is seen as one of the
antecedent theorists and novelizations
of the metaverse came out in 1984 about
eight years before snow crash
where he has this line the future is
already here it's just not very evenly
distributed what you're talking about
exists we have what are called mems
these devices produce ultrasonic sound
barriers that feel like force fields
they're a few inches wide and thick you
can put your hand over on a desk and I
use these examples in my book I've done
these demos you're feeling air but you
have the tactile sensation of everything
from a firm bowling ball to a plush
teddy bear to the sensation of a
crumbling sand castle
that's augmented by extraordinary
technological improvements but also
extraordinary nerve density in your
fingertips atypically compared to the
rest of your body
we're seeing Myriad other Technologies
come Snapchat and Facebook have both
been leading acquirers of what's called
electromyography devices now these are
bands that you'll typically wear on your
Forum or other extremities that capture
electrical signals through skeletal
muscles and what they're able to do is
then not unlike Luke Skywalker or Darth
Vader understand what you would then
want to be doing
and so you wear this device and it's not
a glove that's figuring out what you're
doing with each digit you're wearing a
band that knows what each of your digits
is doing based on the signal you're
sending and so then in a virtual
environment you'll see your hand exactly
even though that input is not actually
being recorded
now you get into these really fun
examples and this is where we get fully
into Ready Player one saying okay I've
now got a lightweight wearable doesn't
require a camera that allows me to play
the piano in Virtual space but do I want
to play a virtual piano and so a famous
demo that Facebook's control Labs has
done shows that you'll control a crab in
Virtual space or frankly in physical one
and you just map mentally your four
fingers to the crab's legs and all of a
sudden you can walk and this is where we
start to get into these weird things
where you don't think it's possible or
you only think of it in The Matrix gone
wrong but the technology is here it's
just expensive and not widely deployed
for now
yeah it's fascinating to kind of think
through how quickly all of this is uh is
coming together
um you not only wrote the book uh you've
not only had a number of uh roles where
you've been uh heavily involved in
setting the strategy of how various
companies should uh think about this but
you're also an investor and one of the
things that I found interesting is you
talk about that you'd rather discover a
Playbook than apply one almost this
Market Observer versus uh kind of a
market predictor if you will talk a
little bit about how do you think of
that are there Frameworks that you use
from an investment standpoint to
understand where the world is going
um and then also uh are there any things
that you're cognizant of uh by being The
Observer rather than the predictor that
could actually lead you to make bad
investment decisions as well
I mean certainly
my Theses could lead me astray but I
think my general working premise is
more things are going to change than
stay the same and it's very hard to
predict specific instantiations I talk
about technology being recursive it's
the same reason why in 1995 you could
have all the engineers in the world all
the cash in the world and the best
technical understanding of tcpip or the
Internet Protocol suite and not build
the right products that's not
speculative we know it Microsoft didn't
TCP didn't Clearly say what the future
was going to look like and so I try to
observe and see what's happening lean
into what the early signs are but to be
open-minded that I'm going to be wrong
I'll give you three examples
we've long believed that some form of
ubiquitous Universal identity online
would be useful would be powerful
remunerative
but for a decade and a half no one knew
how to build it Microsoft tried twice
you might remember the dot NET Framework
why I don't want to sign up for a
universal account from Microsoft what
was the answer the answer was a college
Hot or Not for dorms that eventually
became the world's largest photo sharing
then messaging platform ever
when you take a look at fortnite an
instrumental portion of epic's metaverse
initiative it was itself a spin out of a
you know mostly missed game
had they sought out building a
quote-unquote metaverse they probably
would not have succeeded but instead
they built a battle royale game that
slowly morphed into something more much
like Facebook
and then when you take a look more
broadly no matter the application we
tend to think the new thing is the old
thing but slightly different what was
Skype well Skype was a communications
platform focused on communication to
pstn traditional telephony networks who
were the leaders of the mobile
Communications era Slack
Snapchat Facebook Messenger iMessage
they were built on fundamental different
premises in one case images and AR
filters ephemeral sexting
if you go back to 2007 2008 and I've
done a lot of this there was an absolute
belief that online dating was solved and
what was the answer you spend two to
three hours filling out 600 questions
and then you're scientifically matched
with people that you will then spend 20
or 30 minutes discussing your fit on and
what was the answer to online dating the
online dating answer was the reverse it
was less than three seconds that's how
long the average man spends looking at a
potential match on Tinder it's seven
seconds for women and what's the basis
photos
and so I try to keep that in mind and
just say look we're going to look at
this and say okay it should be Tinder
but with avatars I can guarantee you
Tinder with avatars doesn't make any
sense but that's where the early
Innovation is
one of the companies that we spent a lot
of time with and do quite a bit of work
with is ledger they have self-custody
hardware and obviously in the crypto
space that is a huge thing not your keys
not your coins hold the self-custody
self-sovereignty when we start talking
about the metaverse one of the promises
that I've seen people mention over and
over again is you can take your assets
and kind of move them between these
digital environments how much of this do
you think will end up being uh kind of
software based versus like Hardware
custody and I think of it from as a
potential friction point in the Bitcoin
crypto world people have to learn about
a digital wallet they have to learn
about a physical piece of Hardware it's
scary to people they feel like they
could mess up right it's not just go put
your money in a bank and then the bank
is responsible for it and so how do you
see those types of ideas around
self-custody
um and kind of the self-sovereignty of
these assets actually playing out in the
metaverse
look it's obviously going to be an
instrumental part of all investment in
the future there's no way around the
idea that as the significance both
financially and personally of All
Digital and virtual data not just
Investments but data at large grows that
you're going to be more mindful about
where it's literally stored you're
talking about wallets as a difficult
onboarding experience for many people
the fundamental idea of custody or even
where it's stored is not something we
think of today
cloudflare's founder and CEO talks about
the fact that he believes the primary
use case for Edge Computing is going to
be assurance that your data is stored
nationally right the things that matter
to you don't sit in extra territorial
regions
But to answer your question more
specifically I think this is where we
have to think about function and purpose
we shouldn't think of custody of data or
Hardware in binary the question is where
what when and how we all store things
differently there are some things we
store in our house some things we store
in a bank some things we store in a
storage locker the same reason why that
when you take a look at side chains and
layer twos the right example is that the
degree of security you deploy for a
transaction should be commensurate with
the risk and financial value of that
transaction that's no different from how
the systems work today when you want to
make a wire you have to spend an
extraordinarily large amount of time
validating information complex private
information if you want to buy a
thousand dollar computer from Lenovo
they're going to ask you for your
address and zip code so that they can do
a fraud authentication with your credit
card you want to buy something from
Starbucks well they're not going to ask
for any of that information a two dollar
fraud doesn't matter enough we'd rather
keep the customers going we have to
think about flexible continuums what you
store when where how at which cost when
and that I think is going to be the
answer there's a lot we'll want to
self-custody there's a lot more that
some people of more import or more
wealth will want to self-custody the
Spectrum is what matters
I literally could talk to you for hours
about this stuff because I think it it's
um there's so many things that are
applicable in the short term but also
it's very obvious that over a long time
Horizon uh more and more of this stuff
will become prevalent uh for those that
are listening or watching uh Matthew
ball is the author of The metaverse and
how it will revolutionize everything uh
if you have not yet I highly suggest
going getting the book uh I'm about
halfway through it and uh it is uh
fantastic
um and I think Matthew you know what's
so unique is not just your ability to
understand some of this uh and uh it's
more so also to be able to articulate it
in a way that people understand which uh
which makes the book quite enjoyable uh
where can we send people to find you on
the internet if uh after reading the
book they want to get more of the
information or or consume more of the
content you're putting out
sure so my Twitter handle is at ball
Matthew b-a-l-l Matthew traditionally
spelled and then matthewball.vc as
inventure capital.com or naka.com
awesome Matthew thank you so much for uh
for taking the time uh we definitely
will have to bring you back as this
becomes uh a uh a thing that is more and
more uh obvious to folks
um but I appreciate you putting the time
and effort to write the book and I hope
that everyone goes and gets it
thank you looking forward I hope that
you enjoyed that conversation with
Matthew he obviously has a great grasp
of where the world's headed and he's got
very unique ideas around the metaverse
go check out his brand new book you can
click on the link in the description
there also if you're interested in
Bitcoin go check out FTX us their
sponsors of this video and they allow
you to buy Bitcoin with fees as much as
85 percent cheaper than their
competitors ftxus continues to innovate
around financial markets and I think
that you'll find their product pretty
intuitive go click on the link in the
description to learn more that's it for
this interview and I'll see you guys at
the next one